we have been increasingly concerned with
what's going on with abortion rights in
the united states
and the message that i had
when um
donald trump became president
and started selecting people to the
supreme court was
they're not giving up they're going to
try they're going to do everything they
can to make abortion illegal
and they're going to do it by appealing
cases to the supreme court and they
didn't
and we are now waiting to see what the
supreme court decides
but in the meantime states aren't
wasting any time
oklahoma republicans have passed the law
forcing a woman
to have her rapists baby
it is a near-total ban on abortion with
no exceptions for rape or incest
this isn't going to stop they're going
to keep doing it
governor kevin's tit who's the governor
of oklahoma
says as governor i represent all four
million oklahomans and they
overwhelmingly support protecting life
we want oklahoma to be the most pro-life
state in the country we want to outlaw
abortion in the state of oklahoma
they're not kidding around the bill also
says
anyone found guilty of an abortion think
about the language guilt if you're found
guilty of an abortion
you can get up to ten years in jail
and a hundred thousand dollar fine
there are cases where convicted rapists
don't get ten years in jail
and a hundred thousand dollar fine some
get only a few months jail time
and uh oklahoma governor
uh
signed the legislation and it nearly
bans all abortions in oklahoma the only
exception left the only carved out
exception left
is to save the life of a pregnant woman
in a medical emergency and of course who
gets to decide
what such a medical emergency is
now one of the
odd things about this new law
is that oklahoma already has a law on
the books banning all abortions except
when necessary to preserve the life of
the pregnant person
the old law only has a five-year prison
sentence the new law ups the maximum to
ten years and a hundred thousand dollars
so
it's not even we have no law and we are
anti-abortion so let's pass a law no no
no no it's we already have a law we just
don't think the punishment is strict
enough so let's pass another law
it's become a race to the bottom with
these republican culture wars and we
could all be living i mean modern
technology and medicine and and
innovation
would allow us to be living in an age
uh
sort of sort of led by
science and enlightenment
but we are fighting a group of people
that is determined to have
a country based on extreme christian
fundamentalism and many of these
republicans when you talk to them
their anti-abortion stance is based on a
religious belief
it's not a science-based belief it's a
religious belief now strictly speaking
we have separation of church and state
formally
you're not supposed to be able to
justify a law
with religious doctrine in other words
it can't be written in the law that
because of what the bible says abortion
is illegal
but all of these republicans are using
the bible to justify their votes for
sure i'm not saying there's any way to
prevent that i mean you get into some
really dicey first amendment issues
but understand that we have plenty of
law in this country that is based on
the religious beliefs of the elected
officials and they're entitled to those
beliefs for sure
but strictly speaking
officially those beliefs can't be the
state's justification for a law
uh and and again i'm not saying that
the free exercise of religion should be
suppressed but religion is being used at
the individual level to get all of this
stuff done now there's an important
upcoming event
it is very plausible i don't know i
don't know that i want to call it likely
i want to maintain maintain some
optimism but it is possible that roe v
wade is in its final days because we are
expecting a decision in late june from
the supreme court
last december the supreme court heard
arguments in dobbs v jacobson
uh women's health sorry dobbs v jackson
women's health organization this is a
mississippi case
and it's asking the court to overturn
roe v wade and there are six justices
currently on the court
who are at least open to overturning roe
v wade some of them are eager to do so
22 states already have abortion bans on
the books and so if roe v wade is
effectively overturned by the
forthcoming supreme court decision those
22 states
already have laws that basically ban all
abortions and most of those would take
effect immediately if roe v wade is
overturned a fascinating but grim
reality is that some of those abortion
bans in certain states
pre-date roe v wade they are really
archaic
and those are the anti-abortion laws
that that would immediately be in play
if roe v wade is overturned in late june
by the supreme court so the framework is
already there
and we could be seeing the united states
rapidly accelerate to a sort of sci-fi
dystopian situation with a resurgence of
sort of back alley slash underground
abortion clinics people leaving states
in order to get the services they need
elsewhere uh you know i often say we
don't we don't want to point to a
slippery slope when there's unlikely to
actually be one we don't want to
unnecessarily fear monger that's a tool
of the reactionary right
this is a very real possibility that we
are now facing and there wisconsin's law
makes abortion a felony punishable
by up to six years in prison
that law is over a hundred years old
and it's not likely to be repealed
meaning if roe v wade is overturned
that's the wisconsin law that goes into
place it's not been relevant because of
roe v wade
scary times ahead
very very scary times ahead